you were an early senior executive at
Facebook uh during a period of a lot of
scaling in the company history I mean
it's actually a fascinating period of
human history in terms of Technology
well
in terms of human civilization honestly
uh what did you learn from that
time about what it takes to build and
scale a successful tech company a
company that
has almost immeasurable impact on the
world
that was an incredible moment in time
because everything was so new to your
point like even how the standards of Web
2.0 at that time were being defined we
were defining them you know I mean I
think if you if you look in sort of the
if you search in the patents
um
patent Library there's a bunch of these
patents that like me and Zuck have for
like random things like cookies you know
or like cross-site JavaScript like all
these crazy things that are just like
these duh kind of ideas in 2023
we had to invent our way around how do
websites communicate with each other you
know how do we build in the cloud versus
in a data center how do we actually have
high performance systems you mentioned
data science the term and the answer we
invented this I invented this thing
called data scientist because we had a
PhD from Google that refused to join
unless because he got a job offer that
says data analyst yeah
um and so we said column of scientist
because he was a PhD in particle physics
so he really you know he was a scientist
and I said great you're a scientist here
that launched a discipline that launched
it just made a term you know what's a
rose by any other name but yeah like you
know sometimes words like this can
launch entire
fields and it did in that case and you
didn't I mean I guess at that time you
didn't anticipate the impact of machine
learning on the entirety of this whole
process because you need machine
learning to have both ads and
recommender systems to have the feed for
the Social Network exactly right the
first real scaled version of machine
learning not AI but machine learning was
this thing that Facebook introduced
called pymk which is people you may know
and the simple idea was that can we
initiate a viral mechanic inside the
application
where you log in we grab your
credentials we go to your email inbox
we Harvest your address book
we do a compare we make some guesses and
we start to present other people that
you may actually know that may not be in
your address book really simple you know
a couple joins of some tables whatever
and it started to just go crazy and the
number of people that you were you were
creating this density and entropy inside
the social graph with what was some
really simple basic math
and that was eye-opening for us and what
it what it led us down this path of is
really understanding the power of like
all this machine learning and so that
infused itself into news feed you know
and how the content that you saw could
be tailored to who you were and the type
of person that you were so there was a
moment in time that all of this stuff
was so new
um how did you translate the app to
multiple languages how do you launch the
company in all of these countries
how much of it is just kind of stumbling
into things using your best like first
principles gut thinking and how much is
it like 5 10 15 20 year Vision like how
much was thinking about the future
of the internet and the metaverse and
the humanity and all that kind of stuff
like because the news feed sounds
trivial I'll say something but that's
like changes everything well
you have to remember like you know news
feed
was named and we had this thing where we
would just name things what they were
and at the time all of these other
companies and if you go back into the
Wayback machine you can see this people
would vent would invent you know an I
you know an MP3 player and they would
come up with some crazy name or they
would invent a software product and come
up with a crazy name right and it
sounded like the Pharma industry you
know
glocazamab you know tag your best
friends yeah and you think what is this
this makes no sense and you know this
was zuck's thing he was like well this
is a feat of news so we're going to call
it news feed
this is where you tag your photos so
we're going to call that photo tagging I
mean literally you know pretty obvious
stuff
um so
the thing the way that those things came
about though was very experimentally and
this is where I think it's really
important for people to understand I
think Bezos explains this the best
there is a tendency after things work
to create a narrative fallacy because it
feeds your ego and you want to have been
the person that saw it coming
and I think it's much more honest to say
we were very good
probabilistic thinkers
that tried to learn as quickly as
possible meaning to make as many
mistakes as possible you know I mean if
you look at this very famous placard
that Facebook had from back in the day
what did it say it said move fast and
break things in societal language that's
saying make mistakes as quickly as you
can
because the minute you break something
that's you don't do that by Design it's
not a feature theoretically it's a bug
but he understood that and we embraced
that idea
um I used to run this meeting once a
week where the whole goal was I want to
see that there was a thousand
experiments that were run and show me
them all from the dumbest to the most
impactful
and we would go through that Loop and
what did it train people not that you
got celebrated for the right answer
but you got celebrated for trying
I ran 12 experiments 12 failed and we'd
be like you're the best
can I just take a small tangent on that
is the move fast and break things
has become as like a catchphrase of the
thing that embodies the toxic culture of
Silicon Valley in today's
uh discourse which uh confuses me of
course words and phrases get sort of
captured and so on becomes very
reductive you know that's a very loaded
set of words that together can be
many years later people can view very
reductive can you still man each side of
that so yeah pro move fast and break
things yeah and against yeah
um so I think the pro have moved fast
and break things is saying the following
there's a space of things we know
and a massive space of things we don't
know
and there's a rate of growth of the
things we know
but the rate of growth of the things we
don't know is actually we have to assume
growing faster
so the most important thing is to move
into the space of the things we don't
know as quickly as possible
and so in order to acquire knowledge
we're going to assume
that the failure mode is the nominal
state
and so we just need to move as quickly
as we can break as many things as
possible which means like things are
breaking in code
do the you know root cause analysis
figure out how to make things better and
then rapidly move into the space and he
or she who moves fastest into that space
will win it doesn't imply carelessness
right it doesn't imply
moving fast without also aggressively
picking up the lessons from the mistakes
you make well again let's let's steel
Manning the pro which is it's a
thoughtful
um
movement
around velocity and acquisition of
knowledge
now let's D amend the con case
when these systems become big enough
there is no more room
to experiment in an open-ended way
because the implications have broad
societal impacts that are not clear up
front
so let's take a different less
controversial example if we said you
know Lipitor
um worked well for all people except
South Asians and there's a specific
immuno response that we can iterate to
and if we move quickly enough we can run
10 000 experiments and we think the
answer is in that space
well the problem is that those 10 000
experiments May kill 10 million people
so you have to move methodically when
that drug was experimental
and it wasn't being given to 500 million
people in the world
moving fast made sense because you could
have a pig model a mouse model a monkey
model you could figure out toxicity but
we picked all that low hanging fruit
and so now these small iterations
have huge impacts that need to be
measured and implemented
different example is like you know if
you work at Boeing
and you have an implementation that
gives you a two percent efficiency by
reshaping the wing or adding winglets
there needs to be a methodical move slow
be right process
because mistakes when they compound when
it's already implemented and at scale
have huge externalities that are
impossible to measure until after the
fact and you see this in the 737 Max
so that's how one would Steel Man the
the con case which is that when an
industry becomes critical you got to
slow down
this makes me sad because some
Industries like Twitter and Facebook are
a good example
they achieve scale very quickly
before really exploring the big area of
things to learn so you basically pick
one low-hanging fruit and that became
your huge success and now you're sitting
there with that stupid fruit well so
you're you're I think so as an example
like you know if you had to
you know if if I was running Facebook
for a day
you know the big opportunity in my
opinion was really not the metaverse
but it was actually getting the closest
that anybody could get to AGI
and if I had to steal man that product
case here's what how I would have
pitched it to the board into Zuck I
would have said listen there are three
and a half billion people monthly using
this thing if we think about human
intelligence very reductively
we would say that there is a large
portion of it which is cognitive
and then there's a large portion of it
which is emotional
we have the best ability to build a
multimodal model
that basically takes all of these
massive inputs together to try to Intuit
how a system would react to all kinds of
stimuli
that to me would have been a profound
Leap Forward for Humanity can you dig
into that a little bit more so in terms
of
uh now this is a board meeting how would
that make Facebook money
I think that you have all of these
systems over time that that we don't
know could benefit from
um some layer of reasoning to make it
better
um
what does Spotify look like when instead
of just a very simple recommendation
engine it actually understands sort of
your emotional context and your mood and
can move you to a body of music that you
would like what does it look like if you
know your television instead of having
to go and channel surf you know 50 000
shows on a horrible UI you know instead
just has a sense of what you're into and
shows it to you
um what does it mean when you get in
your car and it actually drives you to a
place because you should actually eat
there even though you don't know it
these are all random things that make no
sense a priority
but it starts to make the person or the
provider of that service
the critical reasoning layer for all
these everyday products that today would
look very flat without that reasoning
and I think you license that and you
make a lot of money so in many ways
instead of becoming more of the pixels
that you see you become more of the bare
metal that actually creates that
experience and if you and if you look at
the companies
that are multi-decade Legacy kinds of
businesses
the thing that they have done is quietly
and surreptitiously move down the stack
you never move up the stack to survive
you need to move down the stack so if
you take that OSI reference stack right
these layers of how you build an app
from the physical layer to the transport
layer all the way up to the app layer
you can map from the 1980s all the big
companies that have been created right
all the way from Fairchild semiconductor
and Nat semi to Intel to Cisco to three
com
you know Oracle Netscape at one point
all the way up to the Googles and
Facebooks of the world
but if you look at where all the Locking
happened
it's by companies like apple who used to
make software saying I'm going to get
one close I'm going to make the bare
metal and I'm going to become the
platform or Google same thing I'm going
to create this dominant platform and I'm
going to create a substrate that
organizes all this information that's
just omnipresent and everywhere
so the key is if you are lucky enough to
be one of these apps
that are in front of people
you better start digging quickly and
moving your way down and get out of the
way and disappear but by disappearing
you will become much much bigger
and it's impossible to usurp you yeah I
100 agree with you
um that's why you're so smart this is uh
the depersonalization and
the algorithms that enable
depersonalization almost like a
operating system layer so pushing away
from the interface and the actual system
that does the personalization I think
the challenge is there there's obviously
technical challenges
but there's also societal challenges
that
it's like in a relationship if you have
an intimate algorithmic connection with
individual humans you can do both good
and bad and so there's risks that you're
taking you can so if you're making a lot
of money now is Twitter and Facebook
with ads surface layer ads what is the
incentive to take the risk
of guiding people more
because you can hurt people you can piss
off people you can
um I mean there's a cost to forming a
more intimate relationship with the
users
in the short term I think you said a
really really key thing which is
um which was a really great
emotional instinctive reaction which is
when I said the AGI thing you said well
how would you ever make money from that
that is the key the presumption is that
this thing would not be an important
thing at the beginning and I think what
that allows you to do if you were
Twitter or Google or Apple or Facebook
anybody Microsoft embarking on building
something like this is that you can
actually have it off the critical path
and you can experiment with this for
years if that's what it takes to find a
version one that is special enough where
it's worth showcasing
and so in many ways you get the free
option you're going to be spending any
of these companies will be spending tens
of billions of dollars in Opex and capex
every year and all kinds of stuff
it is not a thing that money
um actually makes more likely to succeed
in fact
you actually don't need to give these
kinds of things a lot of money at all
because starting in 2023 or right now
you know you have the two most important
tectonic shifts that have ever happened
in our lifetime in technology they're
not talked about but these things allow
AGI I think to emerge over the next 10
or 15 years where it wasn't possible for
the first thing is that the marginal
cost of energy is zero
you're not gonna pay for anything
anymore
right and we can double click into why
that why that is and the second is the
marginal cost of compute a zero and so
when you when you take the
multiplication or you know if you want
to get really fancy mathematically the
convolution of these two things together
it's going to change everything so think
about
what a billion dollars gets today when
we can use open AI as an example
a billion dollars gets open AI a handful
of functional models and a pretty fast
iterative loop
right
but imagine what
um openai had to overcome
they had to overcome a compute challenge
they had to strip together a whole bunch
of gpus that to build all kinds of
scaffolding software they had to find
data center support that consumes all
kinds of money so that billion dollars
didn't go that far so it's a testament
to how clever
that openai team is but in four years
from now when energy costs zero and
basically gpus like you know they're
falling off a truck and and you can use
them for effectively for free
now all of a sudden a billion dollars
gives you some amount of teraflops of
compute that is probably
the total number of teraflops available
today in the world like that's how
gargantuan this move is when you take
these two variables to zero